so this is something i've been wrestling
with personally
uh more on a broader scale than personal
and a little known fact about societies
that i know
or that i believe is that a nuclear
family
is the optimal format
in order in order to have the most
prosperous societies
and this is something i can hold i hold
on to a bit i see it in my grandparents
and my family in particular
i'm sure there's issues there too and
there has been but uh
i kind of wrestle i feel like i have a
responsibility
to not only to myself but also to
the broader community but once i make
myself
you know prosperous then that kind of
bleeds out to a
family and and what's your viewpoint
there
yeah um i'm going to show you the book
design
because i put this on the back cover
give me a second here i'll just open
this up because
what you're talking about i can't even
uh
i'll just give you a quick preview but
it's not i don't even know if it's going
to show up here
no i can't do it that way that's not
going to work
i'll just read it to you but basically
the playbook that you're working with
it's outdated there's a new memo that's
gone out
and there's a yeah that's attached to it
that you have to
understand and the um
environment that your grandparents grew
up in
and then before them yes there was a
prosperous nuclear family
in that society and everything worked
really well but all of that has been
dismantled
yeah it doesn't exist anymore so you
have to understand okay well this is the
reality of the world today
i i have the new playbook i need to
start following the rules here and get
rid of this old notion that i have in my
head
that makes sense yeah what is your
thoughts on uh
you know fake it till you make it you
know if you act as if you're that
successful person you'll eventually
become the person you
you yeah you're deviating a little bit
from the topic but i'll
but i'll tell you well no it's actually
one of the same lines i was going to
get to that it's kind of like a circular
thing how's that
how does it tie into the topic tonight
well if if you see
see it when you when you look at um i
i want to become this person right
and uh well you fake it till you make it
so
you act as if you're a successful person
or to become that successful person
then you are that person doesn't that
kind of tie into the idea
of um the ideal maybe it's my ideal
is to have uh let's say a family
because it'd be prosperous and i act as
if that's the thing
that i would want despite of society
going a certain way
yeah what you're talking about is a law
of attraction which is a little bit
woo-woo for this sort of application
because i mean
you have to take a logical rational
approach
to having kids in today's world like i
said the playbook's changed okay
the old set of rules doesn't apply to
today's world anymore there's a
brand new playbook um i've included a
lot of those elements in my book so when
it comes out in the next couple weeks
you guys will have the benefit of all of
that but
there's a brand new playbook and you
have to get rid of the romantic notion
in your head that if you just act as if
then you will attract into your life
that perfect woman who will
never double cross you never [ __ ] your
soccer coaches
uh you know after the game like all of
those things right
uh there are yeah there are potential
problems that you can run into as a guy
which you can
minimize to some degree in the west
although i'm not
i'm not for it like i'll tell like i'll
tell you guys straight up right here
right now i'm vehemently opposed to
marriage and living in a way that the
state uh sees as marriage which
unfortunately covers if i wanted to have
kids in ontario
i'd be [ __ ] because common law applies
and you're by default
automatically living under the state
rule right so
what options does that leave you with as
a guy well you can move somewhere that's
more friendly towards fathers you know
that's one option
you can do some work vetting you know
your potential partner that's another
option
you can put some legal agreements in
place you can inform yourself of the
lawyer before you get married those are
a few more options
so those are the logical steps that you
got to take to
having kids if that's what you really
want to have and you have to kill off
the
romantic notion of if i just act as if
if i just
you know subscribe to the law of
attraction and find that good girl
then i'm going to you know she's just
going to appear in my life
you know yeah i hear that i'm currently
in a in a
particular situation where i've
been with this well with my girlfriend
for over a year now
and uh she's wanting to move in and uh
basically i kind of laid it down as your
financial situation
is not good right now and i wouldn't
want you to be a financial burden
so i wanted i said hey how about you
work a little bit more you get a little
bit of savings and then we can talk
about it
and i also laid down that i've also said
hey i'm never going to get married just
from listening to what you said and i
completely agree like my father's been
down the uh
the divorce train and that kind of
ruined his life and i
wouldn't miss that uh visually and
literally tore him apart financially
physically
it was it was not good but told you
brother regarding
how old are you again
uh when they got divorced no how old are
you
oh i am 24. dude you shouldn't even be
in a long-term relationship let alone
even considering like
you wouldn't even entertain the
conversation of hey brandon can i move
in with you
no yeah like
in your 20s you lay the foundation for
your life you chase excellence you know
you find out what your purpose looks
like you don't move a chick in
at 24. that's that's
uh you're setting yourself up for
problems that you don't understand right
now
where do you live like what part of the
world you don't tell me what city but uh
ohio i i'm originally from canada
interestingly yeah well i don't know
what the
state laws are like in ohio for common
law
um but there's no upside to her moving
in with you
she moves in with you her competition
anxiety drops
she's not going to behave as well she's
not going to be as pleasant she's not
going to enthusiastically bang you as
often
um you're now responsible for her
and the household um she loses her job
she doesn't make enough hours you're
gonna cover her ass
um i mean you're already talking about
financial problems
with her right now because she would be
a liability so yeah this is
like it doesn't work out from any angle
i mean you'd be better off moving in a
a friend or a brother's you know
somebody else to live with you and
splitting the rent with them
yeah i hear that definitely uh
how far should you take anecdotal uh
evidence like for example
i've noticed when i was i was like 19 18
through 22
23 when i was spinning plates and
playing the marker as you could say and
uh
i noticed that my my attention was
always on like tinder
it was always on going out on the
weekends and now i have something a bit
more stable with this girlfriend
and she knows that hey i'm trying to
chase actually i'm trying to achieve
something
so on the weekends like it's kind of
like she gets like saturday
and then sunday i'm working friday i'm
working rest of the week i'm working
and it kind of lays a foundation of
stability there where she knows i'm
chasing
excellence and she kind of and i don't
have
that attention towards you know the apps
and the going out every single weekend
uh you have any uh ideas there well
that's because you're focused on
building your life man
yeah i mean you've you've set yourself
up that you've got into an ltr with this
check
so then you've switched gears and said
okay well i'm going to chase
excellence and go make some banking
uh better okay ability factor
okay did you hear what you just said
there she allows you to chase excellence
oh my goodness yeah i do
i see that now you guys heard it right
yeah
okay a woman should never allow you to
do anything you don't need the
permission of a woman to do anything
that's like
that's like grossly infused with like
mommy tightness right
i don't know if you're a mesh by your
mom or anything like that like you know
she like overly mother you and
helicopter
she did she would have let me play
football as pee-wee that kind of made me
mad
yeah well you know your girlfriend
allows you to chase excellence
well isn't that convenient
yeah um my the idea was just getting to
the eye of stability opposed to me
trying to i mean especially now cover i
feel like having a relationship
okay okay fine fine go go against
everything
that the red pill says where you
shouldn't get into a long-term
relationship in your 20s
just just do one thing yeah
i i i will take that to heart because
i've
i've been so so far i've been on the no
path for that yeah
well i mean you want to have kids in the
future right and do you have any
recommendations for
like uh i certainly do yes
okay so vet her as wife sock then if if
that's really what you want to do and
you feel like you got your
wild oats sowed and you you know you
spun a bunch of plates and you got a
good notch count you feel like you
understand women
fine fine okay let's let's take a
slightly different approach but do not
move her in
until you've vetted her thoroughly and
you've decided that okay now maybe at 30
i might want to throw a couple of babies
in this one
but don't be stupid i mean
obviously you have your videos for like
vetting and there's a lot of red flags
i've got i've got hours like i did a
private rule zero talk for rule zero
live back in october where we did the
two-day event
and my entire hour was based on vetting
for ltr
or for lifestock because that question
comes up a lot from guys to me
and again i don't support it but i will
i will
shine a light on some [ __ ] that you need
to see so that at least you can walk
into the slaughterhouse with your eyes
wide open and make some better choices
so my plan is to put a course together
and i'll have something that'll be like
six or seven hours long breaking down
every possible um you know scenario and
that will hopefully be useful to you but
yeah just watch everything on the
channel man there's loads of [ __ ] on
there yeah
i'm gonna let you go because i got two
more guys waiting in the background so i
want to move on to make sure they get a
chance cool yeah sounds great thank you
don't move around okay
hang on gotcha
you